on se souvient de ce décollage qui en
principe les premières secondes ça
s'était bien passé puis ensuite les
astronautes d'un soyouz qui ont dû
prendre leur capsule de sauvetage et
revenir sur terre parce que ça ça n'a
pas fonctionné avec nous en direct de
pour moi david saint-jacques astronautes
qui doit partir le 20 décembre dans une
stèle dans une fusée soyouz
tu sais jacques bonsoir à vous bonsoir
bonsoir
alors est-ce que vous pensez que vous
allez pouvoir partir comme c'était prévu
avant ce malheureux incident accidents
des dernières semaines
oui alors où j'ai confiance je t'ai à
baïkonour au kazakhstan pour le
lancement de mes amis nick et alexis qui
étaient à bord de ces fouilles aux lois
qui ne s'est pas rendu en orbite
c'est un rappel à tous que l'espace est
difficile c'est dangereux
ce qui est important c'est d'avoir une
porte de sortie d'avoir toujours une
solution de rechange et ce qui est
arrivé est d'une manière c'est une
démonstration exceptionnelle que le
soyouz est un système très sécuritaire
il ya toujours une porte de sortie et
nos amis étaient de retour au sol
réunis avec leurs familles très
rapidement donc oui j'ai confiance dans
ce système là j'ai confiance que la
commission denquête mis sur pied par nos
collègues russes devaient aller au fond
des choses trouvait m doigt sur le bobo
et on va pouvoir raconter de commencer
les opérations du soyouz vont pouvoir
continuer notre travail à bord de notre
station spatiale internationale parce
que faut rappeler aux gens de 25 jacques
que si le seul
passez moi l'expression mais taxi pour
se rendre sur la station orbitale les
américains on s'en souvient après les
drames de challengers ont laissé tomber
tout ça l'entreprise privée n'est pas
encore prête donc scellé sur you do
c'est rien du tout effectivement des
raisons depuis la mise sous un jour
encore des navettes spatiales
américaines
le soyouz c'est la seule manière qu'on
allait se rendre à bord de la station
donc tout le monde
tout le monde espère le retour des
opérations normales du soyouz on se
prépare à tout en ce moment il ya des
équipes qui travaillent sur les tous les
scénarios possibles incluant le scénario
qu dont personne personne ne veut et où
on devrait laisser la station inhabitée
quelques mois personne ne veut ça parce
qu'il la recherche scientifique
importante à faire à bord d'un médecin
jean vous avez dit quelque chose
rapidement vous avez dit ça nous
rappelle que c'est un métier dangereux
comment vous la vivez vous qui parce que
vous étiez la doublure lors du départ de
la dernière fois ça aurait pu être vous
à l'intérieur ça sera vous
vraisemblablement dans quelques semaines
comment vous vivez les dangers associés
à ce métier alors effectivement vous
savez c'est essentiel au métier
d'astronaute pas seulement de ses
astronautes en tous les métiers un peu
opérationnel si on veut des pilotes aux
policiers aux pompiers c'est un métier
où on fait face à des risques est alors
la seule solution qu'on a
pour minimiser le danger c'est de
s'entraîner de se préparer mais c'est ça
l'essentiel du métier astronautes c'est
de passer des centaines d'heures des
simulateurs pratiquer la réponse aux
urgences se rassurer qu on connaît nos
procédures et on sait comment réagir en
cas de problème
donc quand j'étais là à regarder le
décollage le 2 mai mes copains si on
veut par ce qui me venait à l'esprit
s'esquisse aux cracks
oui on entend des voix il parle à la
stasi parle au sein de contrôle il parle
aux hélicoptères de secours leur famille
est au courant qu'ils sont correctes ça
va bien et je me suis mis à leur place
c'est surtout je pense de déception
qu'ils ont ressentie après toutes ces
années préparation ça peut marcher
le fax est dangereux on sait en fait
chaque astronaute qui se rend à bord est
chanceux de s'y rendre parce que chaque
décollage et plein de risques mais on
est bien préparé on a entièrement
confiance dans les équipes énorme au sol
qui travaillent fort pour un que les
équipements soient le plus sécuritaire
possible et là on est la démonstration
que avec le soyouz il ya toujours une
porte de sortie
un système d'éjection de l'équipage qui
est à toute épreuve et des équipes de
secours qui sont vraiment vraiment prête
à agir
vous retournez dans quelques jours en
russie ensuite au kazakhstan wôrô lieu
le décollage en principe autour du
du 20 décembre parce que des questions
très terre à terre
est ce que votre famille peut vous
accompagner jusqu où vous pouvez avoir
des contacts avec vos proches
parce qu'on veut pas que vous tombiez
maladie lance et très contrôlé tout seul
effectivement il ya un système de
quarantaine
lorsque à peu près deux semaines avant
le décollage l'équipage est maintenu en
quarantaine avec une petite équipe
restreinte de médecins et puis
d'entraîneur et on vit tous dans un
espèce de on y aller car là notre
famille accès à nous après examen
médical
donc ils vont pouvoir venir voir le
lancement on peut recevoir peut-être
quelques heures après avoir été son voeu
béni par les médecins et le médecin de
vol quand les jeunes enfants quand les
enfants vous regarde avec des étoiles
dans les yeux
qu'est ce que vous leur dites pour dire
que c'est important de retourner dans
l'espace de poursuivre cette conquête
l'important c'est réellement c'est
l'importance de l'exploration c'est
l'importance de la curiosité c'est
l'importance de toujours vouloir
agrandir la bulle de notre conscience la
bulle dans laquelle on vient on est
sorti des cavernes pour explorer la
pleine montée les montagnes
après seuls les océans puil avec les
avions maintenant on est rendu là dans
notre évolution dans l'espace et celles
à venir pour nos enfants c'est comme ça
qu'on a conscience de notre planète
c'est comme ça qu'on peut en prendre
soin c'est ça aussi qui nous donne un
peu la réalisation qu'on doit tous
travailler ensemble tous les pays du
monde
je pense que vraiment l'espace est là
pour rester très partie de notre avenir
l'avenir de nos enfants c'est le genre
de pays qu'on veut on veut tous léguer à
nos enfants c'est un pays qui fait
partie des ligues majeures de
l'exploration spatiale
l'a25 genre qu'on va pousser on sera
avec vous le 20 décembre enfin on verra
la date très précise
merci beaucoup de nous avoir parlé en
direct merci merci aux rares